en este vídeo vamos a seguir analizando
las ecuaciones diferenciales de segundo
orden pero esta vez con raíces repetidas
vamos a ver un ejemplo para que quede
todo muy claro supongamos que tengo mi
prima más 4 y prima más 4 james y esto
lo igual a cero lo primero que hemos
hecho siempre en cada vídeo anterior es
sacar de una vez
la ecuación característica asociada es
decir es re cuadrada más 4r más 4 y esto
igual a 0 y de ahí saca sus raíces pero
si se dan cuenta esta ecuación
característica es muy fácil actualizarla
estos ere 2 x r 2 y esto tiene que ser
igual a cero es decir que esto es r
matos al cuadrado al menos sabemos que
tenemos una raíz que raíz pues es igual
a menos 2 y ustedes me van a decir bueno
usar pues entonces qué hacemos con otra
raíz como la inventamos o que no
eso es lo que vamos a analizar en el
transcurso de este vídeo entonces lo que
sí podría decir es que tal vez tendría
una solución de este estilo una
constante por la primera raíz por equis
a la primera y única raíz por equis pero
lo que sí quiero que vean es que esta no
es mi solución general de mi ecuación
diferencial de segundo orden y porque no
es la solución general porque lo digo
esa sería una muy buena pregunta pero lo
que sí quiero que vean es que esta
ecuación general no podría cumplir
simultáneamente las dos condiciones
iniciales es decir no puede existir una
c para la cual se cumplirán ambas
condiciones esenciales
supongamos como siempre que mis
condiciones iniciales son que de cero y
de prima de cero bien lo que sí quiero
que se den cuenta es que si nosotros
tratamos de poner esta función o esta
solución particular en esta ecuación
diferencial y además intentamos que
cumplan las dos condiciones esenciales
esto no va a ser posible y de hecho yo
digo que sería muy bueno probarlo
se me ocurre tal vez darle valores de
cero pero qué valores le puedo dar tiene
que ser un número cualquiera para que
para que no cumpla mis dos condiciones
iniciales al mismo tiempo pero cómo
puedo yo decir que es un número
cualquiera
supongamos no se me ocurre que ya de
cero sea igual a una letra a letra donde
a es una constante y que ya prima de
cero o sea cinco a es decir tengo que de
cero es un numerito y que prima de cero
es cinco veces ese numerito bueno pues
que me quedaría si yo sustituyó mis
condiciones iniciales pues tengo que es
igual hace porque a la cero o sea que se
es igualada porque a la cero pues es uno
bien sustituyendo esto entonces me va a
quedar que ya es igual a a por el ala
menos 2x
ahora bien voy a utilizar mi segunda
condición inicial mi segunda conexión
inicial desde que prima de cero es igual
a 5 y entonces menos 2 por apoyarla
menos 2x que es mi derivada de mi
función tiene que ser por uno
5a y por otra parte pues es lo que
acabamos de derivar menos dos por a por
a la cero porque menos dos por cero cero
pero pues el acero vámonos no me sirve
es 1 y que es dice aquí esto es una
incongruencia no puede ser esto están de
acuerdo
5 a es igual a menos dudosa pues eso no
tiene sentido
con esto acabamos de probar que no es
posible que tengamos solamente está con
solución general porque no se pueden
cumplir ambas condiciones iniciales
simultáneamente pero bien entonces
ustedes me van a decir y cómo encuentra
la solución general para esto primero
hagamos un poco de limpieza y ahora sí
pongámonos las pilas bien y se acuerdan
espero que se acuerden en el primer
vídeo en el que empezó esta serie yo les
contaba acerca de qué es
la rx era una buena posibilidad de
solución y nosotros veíamos que era la
rd x era una posibilidad de solución
debido a que sus derivadas eran muy
parecidas a ella misma pues esta vez me
voy a hacer una pregunta
parecida necesito otra función que
cumpla eso que sus derivadas sean
parecidas y entonces yo pueda tenerla
como solución
así que es hora de ponerle nombre a mi
nueva solución voy a decir que mi nueva
solución se llama g que es una función
que tiene que ver con una primera
función de x le voy a llamar de x que va
a multiplicar a mi solución que ya tenía
a la menos 2x y ustedes se van a
preguntar bueno porque no le puedes una
constante de una vez pues se acuerdan en
el primer vídeo habíamos demostrado que
una constante por la solución también la
solución entonces eso lo voy a hacer
hasta el final lo que sí quiero que se
den cuenta es que ve de x es una función
nueva de x y voy a hacer lo mismo que
hice en el primer vídeo sustituir su
primera derivada y su segunda derivada
en la ecuación diferencial su primer
derivada quién va a ser pues es una
multiplicación de funciones entonces la
derivada de una multiplicación de
funciones tiene que ver con la derivada
de la primera función que multiplica a
la segunda función tal cual sin hacerle
nada más ahora ponemos la primera
función igualita y la multiplicamos por
la derivada de la segunda función pero
la derivada de ella menos 2x es menos 2
al menos dos equis y ahora vamos a
reducir un poquito esto
esto sería mejor si lo pongo como b
prima por el ala menos 2 x menos 2 veces
ven por el ala menos 2 x se ve mejor así
y así va a ser más fácil tratarlo ahora
rompamos la monotonía de colores y vamos
a poner un nuevo color de color pues el
color amarillo que me va a servir de
nuevo para hacer la segunda derivada de
g
es decir que mi prima y la voy a hacer
un poco más rápido que mi primera vez mi
prima por ella menos 2 x menos 2 veces
de prima por el ala menos 2 x estoy
derivando apenas el primer sumando ahora
tengo que derivar el segundo sumando y
lo voy a hacer con mucho cuidado lo
primero que hace es derivar la primera
función y me va a quedar menos 2 x b
prima por el ala menos 2 x desde cuenta
que apenas estoy derivando el segundo
sumando es decir estoy haciendo la
primera derivada con respecto a la
primera función ya esto le voy a sumar
cuatro veces por ella la menos 2 x
porque menos 2 x menos dos es cuatro
bien pero ahora lo que voy a hacer es
tratar de simplificar un poco que mi
prima para esto voy a tratar de reducir
términos y me va a quedar de mi prima
por ella la menos 2x bueno y el
siguiente términos menos 2 por b prima
menos -4 porque es menos 2 más menos 2
que es menos 4 de prima por ea la menos
2 x más 4 veces b por al menos 2 x esto
no se puede reducir con nadie
bueno pues pero ahora lo que voy a hacer
es sustituir todo en la ecuación
diferencial del segundo orden para
sustituir todo quiero que se den cuenta
que hay que tener mucho cuidado en meter
la primera derivada y la segunda
derivada pero toda la primera la segunda
y la función normal tienen que ver con
ella la menos 2x entonces de una vez lo
voy a sacar como factor común para no
complicarnos más la vida voy a decir que
como todo tiene que ver con ella la
menos 2x esto me va a quedar como y
elevado a la menos 2x que va a
multiplicar a quien bueno primero es la
segunda derivada pero son derivadas todo
esto entonces vamos a anotarlo con mucho
cuidado es decir bebé y prima más menos
4 veces de prima más cuatro veces la
función original
ya esto lo tengo que sumar cuatro veces
la primera derivada pero quieras la
primera derivada la primera derivada
hasta aquí entonces tengo que sumarle
cuatro veces esto es decir cuatro por
ver primero pues es cuatro veces de
prima
y después me va a quedar 4 por 28 es
decir menos 8 veces ve bien ya esto
tengo que sumar cuatro veces la función
original es decir la función sin derivar
pero la función sin derivar donde está
la función de sin derivar es esta de de
x por ea la menos 2x entonces cuando yo
lo multiplicó por 4 me queda cuatro
veces como era factor común y me va a
quedar cuatro veces b porque era la
menos 2 x es factor común bien y esto
tiene que ser igual a cero ok esto tiene
que ser igual a cero perfecto pero de
ese cuenta que aquí ya hay nuevas cosas
que nos van a salir de este análisis lo
primero que quiero que vean y esa vez
analizamos muy bien es que la
exponencial nunca se anula es decir que
algunos 2x pues nunca es cero y la
segunda cosa que quiero que vean es que
podamos reducir términos semejantes
fíjense 4 b 4 b menos 8 b vámonos se van
de cero y de hecho menos 4 ven más 4 b
pues también se van
entonces todo esto se va a reducir en
una ecuación muy sencilla que ecuación
pues que a la menos 2 x x baby prima
esto de x tiene que ser igual a 0 pero
se acuerdan que les contaba de la
exponencial exponencial nunca sea nula
entonces de aquí yo puedo concluir que
la que se tiene que anular es baby prima
de x es decir que ve mi prima de x pues
tiene que ser 0 pero esto qué quiere
decir
necesitamos una función cuya segunda
derivada sea 0 si nos regresamos un
poquito y habláramos de la primera
derivada de esta función pues que
tendría que ser baby prima de x fíjense
muy bien que funciona alto derivar la te
da 0 pues una constante muy bien y si
nos regresamos un poquito tendremos que
hablar de una función que tenga que ver
con una constante multiplicada por x más
otra constante y desde cuenta que esto
esta nueva función cumple lo que yo
quería
a cumplir lo que yo quería porque cuando
yo derivó una constante por equis me da
la constante cuando yo la derivó dos
veces me da cero es decir ya por fin
tengo esta función que yo buscaba dvd x
desde cuenta que todo este procedimiento
lo hicimos para encontrar una segunda
solución y ahora ya la tenemos tenemos
que nuestra segunda solución tiene que
ver con c 1 x x + c 2 donde se une este
2 son constantes bien ahora que ya tengo
esta nueva solución yo ya puedo escribir
por fin mi solución general quién va a
ser mi solución general pues va a ser de
dx que multiplicaba a al menos 2 x es
decir tienes bd x pues c 1 x x + c 2 y
todo esto x
al menos 2 x y xi distribuimos esta
multiplicación pues me queda c 1 por el
ala menos 2 x más de 2 por al menos 2 x
esto de aquí es una bien y si tú eres
las personas que quieren una fórmula y
quieren todas las cosas fáciles en la
vida pues qué crees ya tenemos la
fórmula general o la solución general de
migración diferencial de segundo orden
pero
lo que sí quiero que vean es que esta
solución general tiene a igual a menos 2
x una vez multiplicada por x y la otra
vez sin multiplicar por x así es como
nosotros vamos a resolver las ecuaciones
diferenciales de segundo orden que
tengan raíces iguales entonces nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo